[Music]
don't lot of work on the dark universe I
wonder if you can explain what this
means to you or whatever so the the dark
side of the universe this is my area of
research and I wonder if we call it that
just because we're all Star Wars nuts at
heart but we yeah wonderful cipher but
we basically about 95% of the universe
we don't understand and we we use this
term the dark universe to describe that
part of the universe the other 5% is the
stuff that you and I are made up of and
the earth and the moon and the Sun and
and everything you can see this other
95% we call it dark because it's
mysterious and we don't understand it
and there are two entities on the dark
side there's something that we call dark
matter that's about a quarter of the
universe and then something that we're
gonna call dark energy which is about
75% to the universe we don't understand
either but it's very exciting because
when you don't understand something that
big
95% you know it means you're missing
something you're missing a key piece of
the puzzle and so that's the fun and
exciting bit it's trying to work out
what it is we're missing why don't we
understand what we can see out there in
the universe and how is it first sort of
discovered but there's just sort of 95
percent unaccounted home yes to
different parts so that the Dark Matter
side of things that happened back in the
1930s a guy called Fritz Vicky was
looking at how fast galaxies were moving
around so let's see I want you to
imagine embrace your inner cowgirl and I
want you to imagine you're spinning
something around your head okay the
faster you spin something the tighter
you have to hold on to it yeah okay so
he was looking about how fast these
galaxies were moving around and they
were just moving too fast for the
gravity to hold them all together so
when you're spinning something around
your head it's the the string that's
keeping it attached about in the
universe when things are moving around
it's gravity that's keeping things
together so Fritz Zwicky said there must
be additional stuff out there that I
can't see he was German so he cool
dumb cool material which translates as
dark matter everyone thought he was
completely insane now then the fabulous
Vera Rubin an amazing astrophysicist she
came along and had some really really
detailed detailed experiments where she
measured the same affected galaxies
everyone also thought she was mad but
because her experiments were so
meticulous and so perfect it became
really understood that indeed around
every galaxy there's a massive clump of
dark matter so that was in the sort of
70s 80s so that was the first component
of the dark universe now let's move
forward to 1998 where people were
looking at distant galaxies now I've
known since the 1920s that the universe
is expanding so the further you look
away in the universe all these galaxies
are moving away from us but in 1998 they
realized that the galaxies that are even
further away were moving away faster so
not only is our universe growing but the
rate of that growth is getting faster
and faster and I think because for its
Vicki back in the 30s called this extra
matter that was needed dark matter we
ended up calling this extra energy
that's needed to power this expansion
dark energy well I think it's really
just because we're all
Star Wars nuts and we like to say dog
matter and dark energy that's quite fine
okay that's the dark universe in a
nutshell and where has your work taking
you yes both of these entities so my
thing I'm probably most well known of is
for making maps of the dark matter so
it's completely invisible you can't see
it but you can tell that it's there
because of the effect that it has on the
things that we can see and so Einstein
in his theory of general relativity said
that if you have a clump of matter it
will curve the entirety of space-time so
imagine you're the observer on earth
with the telescope looking up at me a
distant galaxy if a big clump of dark
matter was in between us it would
distort the way my face looked and
that's just because the whole of space
and time has been distorted and that's
that I use to map out where all the dark
matter is so that was sort of my early
work and now I've been using that to
also tell me about dark energy because
dark matter and dark energy kind of
one-up each other in the universe so
Dark Matters trying to pull everything
together it's like the strong
gravitational force that pulls
everything together and because dark
energy is causing the expansion of the
universe to accelerate it makes it ever
harder for dark matter to pull those
structures together so by mapping out
where all the dark matter is and how
that changes and evolves with time then
I can tell you can confront various
different theories about what could be
causing this dark energy so yeah my job
is to collect the data extract as much
information as we can from it and then
confront all of these wonderfully varied
and wild different theories on what
could make up this dark side of our
universe so you work from the data
rather than very base I am NOT a
theorist well I'm far I don't think you
can ever do the two independently so my
work is always driven by what the
theories are predicting like I don't
think there's any point in coming up
with a theory that doesn't have
something that you can predict that's
observable from it there's there's not
really much point in coming up with a
theory if you can never test it so I
look at the the theories that people are
coming up with I think how can we
actually test this what data do we need
to test this and over my career we've
worked with various different telescopes
different instruments to build up the
data that we need to test these
different theories and we're even going
so far as testing Einstein's theory of
general relativity itself so this takes
this technique relies on Einstein's
theory of general relativity so we can
use this data to actually test the
theory of gravitation okay so does this
have implications for Einstein's theory
yeah I skip up I work on top of the hill
we're in an observatory so we're on top
of a hill at night I genuinely love my
skip up the hill every day on our vine
stein wrong today and no not yet so the
more and more data we collect the the
smaller errors we get so the the more
precise the measurements become and
everything we do just comes back is
exactly what Einstein predicted but soon
soon we will have the most amazing data
and maybe we'll proven wrong who knows
and but it's exciting this runner trying
to look and decide was yeah why would
that help if you could disprove so when
I was talking about Vera Rubin
discovering this dark matter around
galaxies and I was talking about
spinning this thing around my head okay
so it's gravity that's holding
everything together whereas the things
spinning around my head it's the string
so if our theory of gravity is wrong
then you don't need to invent this
additional Dark Matter particle so I
should say you know this is all theory
that I've talking about this dark matter
and dark energy these are names that we
use to describe entities that we believe
are there but we have no direct proof of
the existence of a dark matter particle
and we really have no understanding of
where this additional energy source of
the universe has come from so one good
theory to explain the Dark Matter
particle is something called
supersymmetric theories which comes from
particle physics but the simplest
supersymmetric theories model suggests
that the Large Hadron Collider in CERN
should have already created some of
these dark matter particles and so
that's putting that theory into some
level of trouble I mean it's a very
flexible theory so it's not not dead in
the water yet but I think over the next
10 years I'm gonna say 20 years if the
particle physicists don't discover a
Dark Matter particle then I will start
getting increasingly worried about as
astronomers we need this this Dark
Matter component in our universe to
understand the observations that we make
and as I say all the tests I've done
avoid spicy generalities so far I've
come back drop I mean it is the best
tested theory that we have and it works
beautifully your your sat-nav wouldn't
work if you didn't understand or well
you don't have to understand it but if
engineers and scientists didn't
understand Einstein's theory of general
relativity your sat-nav wouldn't work so
we know this theory works well but maybe
it works differently in different parts
of the universe these are things that we
can test I think it probably will work
fine but we can test it and that's the
important thing so you're not taken in
by the sort of grand theory of
supersymmetry and so supersymmetry has
lots of elegance so it allows one to
unify the three forces that impact
particles on being liked by the referees
and so there are three four sit there
four forces in the universe there's
gravity which is sort of off on one side
and then we have the electromagnetic
strong and weak forces and supersymmetry
allows you to understand how those three
forces kind of work together power back
in the in the very hot environments that
early universe right after the Big Bang
how those three would have been very
similar and that gives us a good
understanding of where those horses are
coming from and then one can go to the
next step of how do we unite gravity in
as well so it's a beautifully elegant
theory and I think that's why people
have spent so much time working on it I
like the theory because it gives me a
good theoretical grounding for what the
Dark Matter particle will be which is
you know what I'm particularly
interested in and it's genuinely
disappointing that it hasn't been
realized at CERN yet are we actually
found one exciting
and moving on to your work that's
covered the multiverse yes there's this
link to Austin so the multiverse is a
really interesting extension of what we
call inflation theory so right after the
Big Bang the majority of theories about
how our universe was formed requires of
a rapid period of inflation in the very
very early universe and there are many
many different models for how this very
rapid period of inflation could have
occurred but the majority of these
models are called chaotic inflation
Theory models and they predict that not
just one universe would be created that
multiple universes would be created and
this lends itself to the idea of there
being a multiverse you can kind of like
to imagine blowing bubbles and they're
just being lots of bubbles of different
shapes and different sizes around that's
kind of your this this idea of there
being multiple universes in in space
when I first started thinking about the
Monte fuss I really didn't like it
because I thought this isn't a theory I
can test because I can't see anything
outside my own observable universe and I
think I said at the at the start there's
no point in coming up with a theory if
you can't test it and but actually we
can test these theories of inflation so
if we can we can test theories and if
they make a prediction that our
multiverse is the consequence of that
theory then that's a great way of
actually testing this idea of there
being multiple universes out there so we
can test these inflation theories in the
very early universe when the universe
experienced this period of rapid
inflation that would imprint
gravitational waves so it's something
incredibly powerful event that you
should still be able to see the ripples
of now in in gravitational waves now
there's been the first detection of
gravitational waves recently it's not my
area of work it's absolutely phenomenal
what these scientists have managed to do
and so it's just giving them time now to
improve their instrumentation their
technology so we can get down to the
sort of levels where we'll be
to see the remnants of this rapid period
of inflation and then you can really
test these models are these chaotic
inflation models the way to go
does that really infer that there are
multiple universes out there and so what
would be your next research project my
next research project very exciting it's
called the large synoptic survey
telescope is a ten meter telescope in
mountaintop in Chile in the Atacama
Desert is one of the driest places in
the world if you ever go there you're
like constantly putting Vaseline on your
lips it's so dry and that's because you
want your telescope to always be able to
see the heavens so this you're either
above the clouds or there are no clouds
to be had
it's the most amazing sight and when
you're there if you go out at night and
let your eyes get dark adapted it takes
about 10 minutes and when you look up at
the night sky it's bright it's the
funniest thing because everywhere you
look there are stars because it's just
that clear in that dark and if you let
your eyes adapt you can just see stars
everywhere
it's most amazing sight now this
telescope is going to be surveying the
universe but for 10 years it's going to
do nothing else just take image the sky
image the sky do it again and again and
again and you build up that really deep
image so we're going to be looking back
to the universe only a couple of billion
years after the Big Bang I'm gonna be
able to look that far back also this
technique of just looking again in the
game night after night we're also gonna
be able to see things that move so we're
going to find the killer asteroids that
might one day obliterate planet Earth
got that covered oh that's not my
research area but I'm I'm happy that
we've got that covered
and what I'll be doing this a physics
because it's so deep we'll be able to
use those techniques I was talking about
to map out the Dark Matter we're going
to be able to see how that dark matter
is changing and evolving with time so we
can confront these different dark energy
theories I'm going to combine it in with
other data of how galaxies are moving in
these environments so we can also test
gravity theories it's going to be an
exquisite datasets they watch out for
that over the next 10 years as it builds
up its data and this amazing image of
the universe
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you